e sempre che tu non puoi mettere mentre
in italia la barba
ma stai scherzando certo e poi non è
stato bravissimo però gli interni dai
vari modi però madonna devole per
sistemare una telecamera 5 milioni e
mezzo dai signori questo sarà l'anno
della patente io lo dico 2020 io ve lo
giuro
entro due mesi dai la prisma e due mesi
minuto e ben 22 paesi te lo assicuro
quindi marzo 2020 marzo 2020 anche prima
io ho la patente
ok come stiamo andando a farci tatuaggio
c'è questo mio amico che si sveglia la
mattina e mi dice lorenzo andiamo a
farci il tatuaggio perché voi avete gli
amici che si svegliano la mattina che
dicono andiamo a berci un caffe
chiudiamo il girone la faccina
partitella a calcio io i miei amici che
si sveglia le dicono
certo che lo facciamo insieme insieme io
da buon cristiano persona tranquilla
persona pulita cosa gli ho risposto
immediatamente detto certo andiamocela
quando mi ha detto di andare a fare
questo tatuaggio
gli ho risposto di sì lo faccio solo ed
unicamente se te lo fai anche the ok e
lui mi ha risposto in 0,2 secondi ha
risposto sì ok simone siamo l'ho
accompagnato ha fatto il tatuaggio
dovevo farmelo anche io ma non c'era
abbastanza tempo ok quindi io ho
rimandato ad oggi
oggi faccio il tatuaggio è il mio
momento simone purtroppo non c'è perché
lavora però c'è il buon jean che mi
accompagna mi tiene la manina mentre io
urlo come una [ __ ] anche se
effettivamente spero che non finisca in
questo modo non finire cento per cento
così io quando ho fatto questo qua che
l'unico che ho questo se avete tutti
questo qui non mi ha fatto niente niente
una doveva niente completamente niente
infatti questo qua tutte le persone alla
quale spiego dopo portatore non dicono
che vi farà malissimo per me lo devo
fare
dietro colpaccio sul polpaccio fa cioè
solo dietro però ti posso di amare e
priscilla la regina del deserto quando
vuoi quando vuoi
mi spieghi una cosa è successo è
successo quello che succede tutti quanti
giorni della mia vita mi hanno dato una
via siamo venuti nella via dove google
maps ci diceva di venire da noi per il
tatuaggio ma chi siete
ed è sbagliato via adesso il tatuatore
mi rimanderà la posizione
vediamo quanto è lontano ha fatto che tu
sia infinito ragazzi siamo arrivati il
presente grave la ragazza che avete già
conosciuto in un video che questo vada
devi far bene i video se no ti risvegli
in una bara con dei serpenti e facciamo
questa comunque bello quando mi piace
come parcheggiato la b ma come miss di
colore nero comitato ma con le lamette
troppo easy dovrei fare gli strappi di
lecce il latte questo non pagare 18
figurato cielo sull'avambraccio però non
è tanto quello che io la soglia del
dolore che un aldilà formica morta
lennon la formica morta non ad ora non
deve morire
cioè se non voglio sapere nulla di
quello che sta succedendo non succede
niente è successo niente è letteralmente
da guardare ma devo essere uomo devo
essere un uomo vero con difficile no
bravo così mi piace no no aspettano
edibile
no no
no è veramente orribile no ragazzi stava
bene io sono veramente un uomo accusato
[Musica]
meritava tutto il primo punto noi uno in
un culo bene mamma mia come va benissimo
benissimo monaco lo rifacciamo domani
quelli domani quattro donne io ma no è
vero iddio no però non hai capito no
però non è però un viaggio musicale
montaggio musicale
[Musica]
ti sto dicendo che anche io una volta ho
fatto un peccato che bobo è un futuro
tatuato ringrazio quando inizi a
lavorare qua non aveva la faccia del
cliente soddisfatto
una versione che la mia faccia anche
adesso è passato un po di tempo e
possiamo cominciare a parlare ma che
cosa vuoi dire no a mantenerla anni in
faccia io ti urla mia volta conto e si
vede con meta non meno da allora il
disco se questo io pensavo che una volta
iniziato a martellare anche posto anche
di mercato facesse male se anche nel
caso dovesse far male dopo un po si
abitua al dolore non lo senti più se no
no non è così fa male continua fa sempre
male male fa male quindi cosa che vi
devo dire ok
che cosa vi posto di simone alla fine
cinquecento i bianchi sono sistemi di
amiche di bianchi bianchi famosissimi
bianchi che servono che servono a
rompere ma servono tagliata e poi
vediamo tra leader è berlusconi come
come sta bene ricordiamo allora io
veramente la soglia del dolore di un
bambino di due anni quello che però sono
stato bravo e quest'anno riusciamo a chi
medici dove vi facciamo la puntura è il
momento
madonna
ma il gigante cava h veramente figo
dello specchio
aspetta aspetta equa e sto perdendo tipo
fuori minecraft se ne porta nova ben 107
in 3d che dal 6 marzo via cioè uomo
complimenti bravissimo veramente
bravissimo completa anche perché c'è
veniva da cani
facevo un cassetto questo non è mia e
questo fa veramente ridere in confronto
c'è ero così e parlavo dei casi c'è qua
proprio nero in afghanistan può mettere
busi non ho detto niente
questo è stato forse la migliore idea
che abbia mai avuto che non la vota
viola votassimo questo video quindi
chiudiamo qui chiudiamo quasi bellissimo
che io chiedo per i miei video
sì questa è stata una grandissima
esperienza mi sono voluto punire così
lasciate un mi piace se vi è piaciuto
vedermi soffrire non per il tatuaggio da
quello iscrivetevi al canale schiaccia
dalla campanellina che giampiero adesso
mette in editing però già perché sei
bravo però a queste cose nell'immagine
ancora e noi ci rivediamo come sempre
non urlo perché sono mi vergogno non
possiamo video
[Musica]
shogun ii